uh sorry about texting you during that
question that was my bad
uh chris uh uh
i got a question man look i'm the fan
here i didn't play nothing
but i sure did see you guys on that
banana boat and i just want to know
there you go my question really is this
you got drafted a no five
all these guys were in 03 how did you
join this group
and and i know that you guys have such a
special friendship but how did you as
the young guy
join this group what's the story there
and i just want to show this picture
lebron got a nice arch in his back jody
this picture dog come on brian brown oh
man
hold on hold on let chris talk because
so chris tell me
what was it like seeing the reaction to
that picture
underdog put that on a t-shirt
all right
oh we need now some music for lebron i
like nick
all right all right let me bring this in
wait
chris uh with that picture though it is
iconic
coffin coughing again
oh all right hold on chris chris how did
you how did you join the group since you
were the young guy
so those guys draft class 03 but me and
braun actually the same high school
class
right so me and bruh she played in the
mcdonald's all american game together
we played you against each other since
we was 14. you know what i mean
yeah uh yeah mellow knew each other for
playing au basketball
my college roommate was his high school
roommate and then
actually when i was in college uh
playing on the usa team
my coach coach tom crane he put me on
the phone one time with d wade while he
was in the nba
and so then what was 2000 what was that
0-6-d
when we all played on the usa team
together yeah that summer
yep that summer we spent 35 straight
days ago
35 straight days together and that's
that's sort of when it was uh
yeah how come mello wasn't on that
banana boat
long story lols yo cp
i want to talk about